it's not often you get a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky
i love you
i love you too
love is in the air as preparations are
underway for benifer's second wedding
celebration ben affleck and jennifer
lopez are set to tie the knot again at
ben's georgia estate and e.t has learned
it's nothing short of spectacular it's
just a dream come true
dreamy indeed a source tells e.t the
actors waterfront property is completely
private spanning 87 acres with a 6 000
square foot house and a helipad and shed
for seaplane arrival
preparations for the backyard tent
started a week and a half ago it's
massive we do our best it's located
about 45 minutes south of savannah in a
town called riceboro on georgia's
hampton island and holds a special place
in the couple's heart a source tells us
ben bought the home when he and jen were
just dating the first time around and
they both loved how they could be
low-key and private there quote ben and
jen redid the house to be to their
personal taste it's no question that ben
and jen love the location we're told ben
tried to sell the property but it didn't
have success on the market so now it
seems like fate played a part in
securing this fairytale venue our source
says ben and jen feel like it was meant
to be quote they are very happy to have
the home and can't wait to celebrate
their special day there together we're
super happy what can i tell you we're
just having a good time before guests
roll in for the wedding extravaganza
biddeford fueled their energy by
stepping out for a family coffee date an
eyewitness tells e.t the couple hit up a
local java joint for iced lattes and get
this ben shelled out a 200 tip
[Music]
as for how their a-list guests will
likely arrive to the exclusive party a
separate source tells us they have
options by car boat and plane we're told
the groom's choice of transportation by
air quote ben often arrives by plane
there's a small airport and seaplanes
are near his residence
it's exciting we're itching to see and
hear all about how this lavish
celebration turns out you know e.t will
keep you posted every step of the way
and if j.lo's dress is anything like her
first gown at their vegas nuptials
prepare to be wowed
i feel
excited you look gorgeous
somebody's getting married
[Music]